new memorial continues to grow outside
of emerald sweets all day long people
leaving those messages for a life lost
far too soon
that's where joe moller now joins us
live joe
yeah that vigil will take place here in
about an hour's time we are hearing that
uh mari's father is expected to be here
now the memorial has been growing
throughout the day we've been watching
people drop off balloons
candles stuffed animals people have been
writing on this post right here rest in
peace amari and
you are getting justice now this is
outside the emerald suites and they give
you an idea of how close this was
uh to the seagull suites where his body
was found you can see
that brown building right there so this
is just yards away
from that location now there was a
number of people outside there earlier
today
when this all unfolded including juana
salazar who was
helping search for amari we went there
last night and we put some candles down
and we put teddy bears the football down
and a sign down we'll be back here
tonight there's relief because he's he's
he's going to rest he's going to he's
going to be laid to rest now
after the arrest of 27 year old terrell
rhodes that is amari's mom
mom's boyfriend that is i was in contact
with amari's father's family they had
asked for privacy however a
representative
from nevada child seekers who was
helping with this search was with them
last night and said they were very
shocked to hear about
the arrest that was made in connection
with this now there is a vigil set here
where this memorial continues to grow it
will be happening at six o'clock they
are expecting
a big presence reporting live here near
twain in paradise joe muller 8 news now